So, is a $50 a month digital PDF that
you can read in 30 minutes worth it?
Well, we're going to find out in this
video because we are talking about the
very prestigious Adventures in Copy Land
by Daniel Thrasel, of which I have been
a subscriber that I've put my own money
forward for the last 25,
not five, it's two fives. 25 issues. I
spent $50 a month for the last 25
issues, which means I've spent over a
grand of my personal money investing in
this newsletter. So, these are going to
be all my raw, real, unfiltered thoughts
that have not been seen, pre-approved,
or filtered by Daniel himself or anybody
else. And this video is not sponsored.
He is not telling me what to say. He
doesn't even know I'm making this video.
So, with that being said, I'm going to
break this video out into three
sections. If you watch my Ben Sto email
players video, it's going to be the
exact same format. We're going to be
talking about the cons of joining the
Adventures and Copyland newsletter.
We're going to be talking about the pros
and the cons, which are basically their
pros and con depending on how you see
it. It's going to be your personality.
And so, I'm going to throw those out
there as well. But without further ado,
I want to jump in starting with the con.
Now, I'm going to be honest. I sat down
for a while and I had the hardest time
thinking of a con. And uh and I'm not
just saying that because I uh enjoy
Adventures in Copyland or I'm a big fan
of Daniel Thoras, which I do candidly
and upfront. I I'm a huge fan of Daniel
Thoras. I'm a big fan of this
newsletter, which you'll see when I talk
about the pros and the cons. But even
so, I still want to give you an honest
review and I want to try and find
something that if there is a con, be
honest about it. And the only con that I
can genuinely think of is that if you
are a copywriter, you join this
newsletter, the only con is that if you
cancel it, you're blacklisted. That is
literally the only con I can think of.
And and it's a con because to me, it's
so valuable. We're about to dive deep
into that in the pro section. It's so
valuable. But but if you do cancel it
for whatever reason, you're trying to
clean up your subscriptions or anything
like that and you decide, I haven't read
it in a while, you cancel it, you can't
come back. I think that's a con. I think
that sucks. But if the newsletter is
working the way that it's supposed to
work and it's making you money, it's
helping you grow your business, then you
would never do that. I've never
considered cancelling once, but that
would be a con. But with that said,
let's talk about the cons and then we'll
get to the pros, okay? Let's talk about
the cons, things that potentially could
be cons to you, but are not necessarily
cons to me, right? I'm going to put
those out uh real clear so you can
decide whether this is a pro or a con
for you. Con number one is that the
newsletter is 100%
digital. This actually is a con to me,
but it not it may not be a con to you.
So, being 100% digital, Daniel has his
Adventures in Copyland Daniel Thrust app
where you can access his courses and
other kinds of like podcasts that he's
on and that's also where he uploads
Adventures in Copyp. The reason this is
a con to me is because I don't care to
scroll my phone or scroll my iPad and
read long form content digitally. Uh, I
like paper newsletters, right? I like
paper pen, paper books, right? Things
like that. So, when I get email players
and it comes in the mail and I can read
paper with some coffee at my desk and I
highlight it and all those things. I
just enjoy that, right? I enjoy that
infinitely more than the digital side.
But for you, you may not want a bunch of
paper. You don't like reading paper. You
don't want to carry these. If you lose
it, you lose it, right? Uh, things like
that. So, it is your personal
preference. Con to me, but big pro to a
lot of other people. Another con, uh,
which is a huge pro for me, but maybe a
con for you, is that it is mostly
written. Almost every single issue that
Daniel puts out is a like 10 to
15,000word issue that you would sit and
read as opposed to video format, which
is hilarious because a lot of you guys
know that I actually did a collaboration
with Daniel Thrasell uh for an
adventures in Copyland where I taught
ecom emails Daniel Thrasell style. We
did it together. And my issue with
Daniel was all video-based. I mean,
there was some writing and templates and
things like that we included, but it was
mostly videos and and candidly, I'm not
the biggest fan of the video issues
because again, I don't want to just sit
there and watch my phone all day and
watch courses and things like that. But
even so, I do think it is a big pro that
most of them are written. And I think
the right person, the right copywriter
who reads and writes a lot because if
you're a copywriter that those are the
only people that should be interested in
this is uh you hopefully read a lot,
right? Your reading is your preferred
method of learning otherwise I would be
so confused how you became a copywriter.
So I understand that video consumption
is a big thing amongst everybody else
but amongst the smartest people and
great copywriters, right? Reading is our
number one preferred method. So I do
think this is a big pro. Con number
three is that it is very personality
based, which again would make no sense
to me that if you are to subscribe to
Adventures in Copy Land, but you don't
already understand and appreciate
Daniel's personality, whether it's his
spicy trolling uh against other trolls
or or his writing style, his formatting,
uh his bombasticness, whatever it is,
right, that that translates to
Adventures in Copy Land. But I would
dare say that his emails are far more
like story driven and entertainment
driven where adventures in Copiland are
definitely far more valuedriven. Like
you are learning. He is breaking down
concepts and teaching you things in it
but with his personality. So it's still
really fun to read. It's really
enjoyable. If you like Daniel's
personality, 10 out of 10. But if you
don't like it, it annoys you, you're
irritated for whatever reason, then it
doesn't matter how valuable the content
inside is, you would be frustrated
because it's littered with his
personality. Pawn number four is that
this is a very quick read. I think this
is a huge pro that I could finish
Adventures in Copy Land in, you know,
30, 35 minutes, but a lot of other
people would see it perspective-wise.
Again, I think the wrong people, like if
you see this, if you see something, you
say, "Well, it's a digital PDF and it
cost me 50 bucks and I can read it in 30
minutes. I could buy three books for
that price, four or five books for that
price. Yes, but that's not what you're
paying for. You're paying for the
specific knowledge and the tactical
ability to take that knowledge, extract
it as fast as possible, and make your
money back ASAP. Okay, that's what I'm
paying for is when I read an Adventures
in Copy Land, it's so tactical, which
we'll talk more about in a second, and
it's so helpful, practical, that in 30
minutes, I could walk away and say, I
know exactly what I'm going to do with
that, and easily make 50 bucks, if not
10 times more, if not 100 times more.
I've taken a $50 issues of Adventures in
Copyland, used it to craft one of my
email launches that made me six grand in
3 days. So that is literally, you know,
a 100x return on my money. And the last
pawn is again up to your choice. $50 a
month. That is what people would
consider an expensive subscription.
Okay? So relative the average American
household subscription is about $15 a
month. That is the average American
subscription in the house. Okay? Think
Netflix, think Hulu, think Disney, think
things like that. Okay? So $15 a month.
So, when you talk about a $50 a month
investment of a subscription, a
recurring subscription, now you're
talking about $600 a year. Okay, this is
three to four times what the average US
subscription is. And a lot of people
already have subscription fatigue. So,
$50 a month. Is it considered expensive?
Yes, technically it is considered
expensive, but perspective-wise, I have
never once had the $50 a month card
charge me and I not think, "Wow, I can't
believe this isn't 250 a month. I can't
believe this isn't 300 a month." Because
what I get out of it is far more than
what I put into it. Right? I know guys
that are pumping out $5,000 courses that
don't even hold a candle to one issue
that I may purchase. So, if you end out
the year with a $600 investment into 12
issues, that could change the entirety
of your copywriting business and you
think that's expensive, I do not think
that Adventures in Copyland is for you.
Actually, I can tell you right now,
don't even think about it. If $50 a
month is a lot to you to invest in this,
then then not for you. either you don't
have an established business, you're not
an established copywriter, or for for
whatever reason, you're just not in an
area that allows you to afford something
like this. This would be a luxury
service, which is totally fine. Okay,
that's not for it's not for everybody.
However, uh when I see this, I'm like, I
can't believe that this is the price
that it's the price. I've I've never
even once considered cancelling it
because the the the return on investment
is just way too high. So, is it
expensive? Relatively. Uh is it worth
it? Yeah, every dollar. Now, with the
pawns out of the way, right, you put
them in your category, pros or cons,
whatever you feel. I'm just giving you
my opinion, which this is my channel. I
can give you my opinion. I can say
whatever I want to say. It's my channel.
You start your own YouTube channel if
you want to give your opinion or drop it
in the comments. You know what? In fact,
you should like rage comment and just
like get everybody just rage comment in
the comments. Just put so many comments
in there that YouTube is like, "Oh my
god, this video is getting so much
traction. It's going crazy. People are
going crazy on this." And it just like
throws me up in the algorithm. Yeah, go
ahead. Rage comment. That would be
amazing. But while you do that, I'm
going to move over to the pros. Okay, so
the pros of adventurous and copyulent,
which I have quite a few, but I've
boiled it down uh to my favorite ones.
And pro number one is that it is highly
tactical. Okay, so one thing that you
may have noticed uh when I did this for
the email players adventures in copy
lane is that Ben Settle's email players
are far more like strategic and
philosophical. Like Ben thinks like way
up here and and he does not really break
it down for you. It's not giving you
like step by step. He's not giving you
like listicles one, two, three. Very
rare does he do issues like that. This
is more like how I think type thing.
Now, Daniel does have some of these. In
fact, he recently did a more
philosophical approach issue, but
they're very rare, actually. But I just
I just really like the tactical
approach. Everybody likes the tactical
approach. And every single issue that
Daniel comes out with is just such a
clear like I walk away with like one,
two, three. I know exactly what I'm
going to do. And every time I try it,
man, makes me money. Big pro number two
is that Daniel always either introduces
an entirely new concept that I've never
heard of ever in my life. Basically, he
invents something or he says some sort
of concept I have heard in such a new
way that it blows my mind. So, my old
mentor used to tell me that you either
have to say something new, say it
differently, or say it simpler. Daniel
somehow has this magical ability to say
say something entirely new. And if it's
not entirely new, he can say something
that you've heard before so differently
that it feels entirely new. I don't know
how he does it. I don't know if he does
this intentionally. But literally every
single issue that I've ever gotten from
him, I'm like, "Oh my gosh, I didn't
even think of that. How did you even
think of that? I don't understand how
you comprehend. How did you move from
one to three?" Like, I just don't
understand. And and it reminds me very
much of the Eugene Schwarz like uh
copywriting is assembled and it just
feels like he's assembling these crazy
ideas and putting them together into a
way that you've never heard. So I just I
love that. I love that cuz it doesn't
feel like you're going to get
regurgitated YouTube content or
something that you've already heard in a
course before or anything like that.
Lastly, the big pro is that it is hyper
hyperfocused. It is for copywriters.
Okay, so there's a lot of newsletters
out there. Um, uh, the Dan Kennedy
newsletter, right? Magnetic marketing,
and then you have, um, and then you have
like Matt Fury's newsletter, you have
Make It Rain Monthly, uh, Chris Orysy,
and then you have email players, Ben
Settle, and they're all really, really
good. But one thing that I noticed that
Daniel takes it to the next level is
that he is so focused on copywriters
that you feel like everything is so
applicable to you. because there are
times when you read those other
newsletters and they're a little bit
broader, a little bit more about
marketing and you definitely can apply
it to copywriting, it it takes a minute
to get there. Um, but at the same time,
when you get something for copywriters
by a copywriter, it's so hyperfocused
that you every issue just feels like,
oh, this is for me. This is exactly I
didn't even know I was going through
this that I had to learn this. I didn't
even know I had this issue like this
challenge in my business and now I know
how to overcome a challenge that I
didn't even know I was struggling with.
So, it's just a big big big win uh to be
hyperfocused on that. But that's it to
wrap up the video. Should you subscribe
to uh Adventures in Copyland? Well, if
you are a copywriter, uh you have a
genuine business, a real business, you
are already making money from
copywriting. So much money to the fact
that $50 a month, you sneeze at it, you
can't believe that $50 a month would
even be considered expensive. Then yeah,
I think you should subscribe and that
you like Daniel, right? should like
Daniel's emails and all those things. Uh
I I definitely think it's worth it, you
know, and if you don't like it, you can
cancel, be blacklisted forever, and it
is what it is. But other than that, it's
very hard to find any cons. I do
recommend uh you check it out. So, I did
link Daniel's email um below so you can
subscribe to his emails. If you enjoy
his emails, he promotes Adventures in
Copy Land so often uh that that you will
definitely have an opportunity to sign
up. But first, I highly recommend that
you join his email list and then just
see if you enjoy his emails. And if you
do, fantastic. Then you can move forward
with that. Again, he did not pay me to
do any of these. I just really enjoy the
letter and I want to see great people
who put out great work to continue uh to
get the accolades for all the stuff that
they've done. So, so big kudos to him.
If you enjoyed videos like this and you
want me to review another newsletter or
anything like that, you want me to
review a course or whatever, just let me
know. Drop a comment down below. But
before you go, please, it would mean a
lot. Would you like and subscribe uh to
the channel to the video? Like the
video. Subscribe to the channel. Tells
me that you enjoy the content, that you
want more content like this. I mean, I
just dished out over $1,000 to get you a
nice review, right? Come on. Least you
could do is like, comment the video. You
know what I'm saying? Dang it. So, yeah.
Enjoy that. Also, before you leave,
heads up, I did pin a comment. There is
in the description below and in the
comments, a free gift from me.
Copyrightiting catalyst 63 cash cow
copywriting tips to help you in your
business. Doesn't cost you a thing. And
I think it is worth an entire uh issues
of adventures and copyland money in
itself. I.e. I could charge $50 to $100
uh just for copyrighting catalyst, but I
won't. It's free. You're going to enjoy
it. Just put your email, tell me where
to send it. You'll get it immediately.
And I hope it makes you a ton of money
and teaches you a bunch of
copyrightiting tricks that you did not
know. So that's it. That's it for today.
I will catch you on the next